is like a cultural thing like you just  think it's easier when they have the  same culture yeah I just think yeah  we've um with a lot of problems well  fundamentally I think that um  human civilization isn't far gone enough  to accept interrelation into interracial  relationships what they are so I think  people who enter them now are like marks  for the cause because with all the with  the high intentions around race  relations and stuff like that it just  makes it a lot more difficult I don't  think it's a bad thing  um it's necessary  um but I just think it's just it's  difficult right now as as well we're  just not there yet as a civilization